en tunisie les mesures exceptionnelles
du président kaïs saïd continue de
susciter la colère de ses opposants de
plus en plus nombreux l'illustration
samedi avec un sit-in rapidement
interrompue par les forces de l'ordre
les activistes a dénoncé des violences
policières et une atteinte à la liberté
de manifester un correspondance à tunis
de bassem chibi
il avait attendu le week-end de la date
anniversaire de la révolution pour se
faire entendre mais leur action a
rapidement tourné à l'affrontement
samedi les membres du collectif citoyen
contre le coup d'état ont décidé de
prolonger les festivités avec la tenue
d'un sit-in pour dénoncer le coup de
force du président sayed du 25 juillet
dernier et a exigé un retour à la
démocratie un sit-in rapidement maîtrisé
par les forces de l'ordre présentes sur
l'avenue habib bourguiba qui ont saisi l
les tentes et les chaises préparer pour
l'opération des heurts ont éclaté les
forces de l'ordre ont procédé à
l'arrestation de 12 militants pour
trouble à l'ordre public et outrages
suite à la tentative de certaines
personnes d'installer des chapiteaux sur
l'avenue habib bourguiba le samedi 18
décembre 2021 à 14 heures pour être
exploité dans le cadre d'un sit in en
violation de la loi des unités de la
sécurité civile sont intervenus pour
interdire une telle installation et
faire appliquer la loi il a été relevé
des agressions contre des cadres de la
sécurité civile une version est réfutée
par les activistes qui dénoncent un
démantèlement sauvage et violent ou
encore des arrestations arbitraires pour
jaguar mbarek chef de file du mouvement
l exécutif et tout pour écarter
l'opposition ainsi que la société civile
il dénonce une violation des acquis
démocratiques de 2011 et exigent la
libération des militants arrêtés écoutez
le c'est clair elle est claire
c'est à dire qu'à une sorte de
discrimination fait une sorte de
discrimination entre le traitement des
manifestants et des manifestations pro
pouvoir pour ou au départ au président
de la république
en contrepartie un traitement
d'exclusion de discrimination de
violence contre à l'égard des
manifestants qui sont contre le coup
d'état ça s'est produit d'abord par
rapport au festin des parties de jeu
mûri est à 14 et c'est qu'ils ont été
exclus du de l'avenir nos bolides et
aussi des manifestations qui ont été
organisées par citoyen contre contre le
coup d'état on demande aux gones retour
à l'état de droit
l'arrêt des mesures d'exception et un
retour à l'état de toit depuis la sous
direction de la lutte contre la
criminalité de la garde nationale a
procédé à l'audition des activistes
interpellés pour outrages à agent dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions quant au
parquet de tunis il a ouvert une enquête
pour déterminer les causes exactes de
ces débordements